ce que vous préférez chez vous en vous
physiquement mais physiquement et dans
la tête enfin bah oui mais alors là on
rentre dans le privé pur porc
non non c'est des choses vraiment que je
peux pas répondre
qu'est ce que vous préférez vous
vous allez bientôt prendre les moyens
pour dior et ma mère ça peut être la
main droite on sait que oui mais ça
d'ailleurs spectateurs est ce que vous
détestez chez vous que je déteste chez
moi c'est tout ce qu'on déteste tous
c'est-à-dire l'impuissance de la lâcheté
l'incapacité à et très peu ouvert d être
mais bref tout ce qui fait non c'est
personnel ou si c'est non non ça fait 25
ans que je suis sur un divan vus comme
des as ou dit allen ça valait un tout
petit peu mieux mais je n'ai pas jusqu'à
livrer les vrais secrets
j'aime mon cachot le plus grand moment
de votre vie
jean laurent cochet quand il a illustré
mis en lumière une phrase mystérieuse de
de feydeau est douce et mais ne pensez
pas que c'est quand même con labro vous
retrouver dans ce dans ce boîte de nuit
angoulême est en train de premiers
moments de ma vie c'est aussi les
premiers flirts une femme de 30 ans
incroyable avec une énorme poitrine avec
un chèque il andré croyable m'a collé
contre 1 c'est elle qui à gogo rue du
beaujolais s'étaient tenus par ben simon
et pol pas fini ils sont très âgés
maintenant et je marchais jamais 15 ces
gens vous avez un jean hyper serré puis
j'avais des carmes il mon temps avec des
boucles j'étais un petit mec et je ne
traiterai le web
non j'ai 48 ans donc je suis un peu en
fin de piste à cause de revenir main et
et elle m'a collé contre le mur et elle
m'a embrassée sur la bouche
je crois que c'est le plus beau moment
de ma vie j'ai senti une langue
savait pas s'il fallait bouger ou aller
plus loin j'ai été immobilisé et ça
c'est un très grand moment après j'ai
mis la main sur les seins j'ai dit c'est
pas possible
et après lentement de manière inquiète
je suis descendue vers ce continent noir
les choses si inquiétante sur lequel sig
moon a tellement travaillé parce que
tous les gens qui frime en disant c'est
comment je la prends moi j'y crois qu'à
moitié droit qu'à moitié
magalas la gravité la grande ville et
sexuelle etc les mecs
les mecs sont totalement terrorisés ça
sera un autre sujet des missions les
autres parisse le pire moment de pierre
moment de masi le pire moment de ma vie
c'est les devenir un peu solennel
sceller les mauvaises les inquiétudes
quand on passe des choses un peu
inquiétante que dans le corps médical
quoi faut être simplement être une
culture qui attend des réponses 1 est
entre ces les pires moments de ta vie et
puis et puis voilà après y'a plus rien
ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans la
vie
télé achat non ça c'est un peu du
conformisme canal+
qu'est ce qui me fait prêts reer virait
quand il dit juste leblanc grand rôle
bigné digne et non c'est pas du tout je
sais qui a rien pour moi dans le
prochain est ce qu'il ya vraiment
interrogé en fait parce que je suis en
train de m'interroger mais aussi au
départ avant les conflits où j'avais pas
pensé quand même fait mais c'est
pourquoi est ce que j'ai l'air comme ça
parce que bon j'ai été déstabilisé et je
suis vraiment prêt ce que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour toi il faut qu'on m'a
fait reposer une bonne chose
à rome les gentils qui me donne un grand
rôle de rose et noir il avait loupé le
noir et à mon avis paraître basse et
j'ai un tempérament plutôt anxieux donc
à part quand je travaille je suis plutôt
flipper non mais c'est parce que vous
êtes à dépersonnaliser que vous êtes un
grand comédien c'est parce que vous
n'existez pas oui si vous existez mais
moi je préférais pernaut présentateur de
13h régionales j'y vois prometeur qu'est
ce qu'on a sur le midi palavas bon tu
vas crime très jolie lettre quand j'ai
fait une anomalie à carnot qui est un
moment important dans l'existence c'est
que pour moi le jour où j'ai rencontré
le 13 heures le régional j'ai vu un
grand j'ai vu un homme normal tout va je
pense que si on mettait un électro de
bonheur entre pernaut le présentateur du
13 heures que j'aime beaucoup et
montrent qu'ils ont pouvait nous coller
quelque chose sur l'atome ou sur leur
sur les cuisses et qu'on dise d'autres
bonheurs 12,1 par exemple sur pernod ça
doit aussi les 8 9 12 14
moi c'est plutôt un deux au maximum sur
scène douze presse mais ça dure une
heure quarante cinq par jour
tout le reste du temps je pense que la
vie de pernod d'ailleurs l'avis de
pernod pardonnez moi ça vous intéresse
mais perdons nous
vivement un pernaut perdre ça nous
intéresse dans une chose très simple
c'est que il m'a dit c'est hallucinant
parce que comment se fait-il que vous
savez comment je rentre chez moi parce
que j'avais parlé qu'en le voyant au
trésor je visualisais sa rentrée chez
les 8 bat avec la voiture j'ai fait ça
fera une peugeot way ou une renault et
puis que sa femme était en train de
finir
et puis quelle il arrivait pernaut pisé
chérie qu'il veut que je mette un peu de
buch
tu vois ce que je dirai la femme dit au
maire tu sais très bien je m'ennuie
jamais allée gilet à laraque et ça c'est
un enthousiasme est vital au niveau et
qui n'osent rien pas même nitya il faut
quand même le fight dépressif pour
rentrer après le boulot et dire à sa
femme je fais un peu de buch et la fin
c'est aux côtés d'andré luiz terry
c'était drôlement les 20 d'écart 1 qui
met la bûche et qui a failli faire je
vais garder la manière il va garer la
bagnole il revient ça c'est un être qui
va bien il a pas les spinosaures il n'a
pas lu ni jean vit totalement pernaut
j'en fais pas un cheval de bataille
médiatique
en fait
il est